you're back I'm here with the stars of
Game of Thrones Jon the fans of Game of
Thrones are very opinionated what is the
strangest thing that you've been
confronted with the strangest opinion
that you've been confronted with well
it's a fact really more than an opinion
I was in London and a guy came up to me
so he Game of Thrones when ta said I'm a
huge fan I went well fantastic I'm
really he said can I ask a question I
went you just have nothing
we said why are you still so fat and I
said well what he said no no I just
don't believe it just don't believe it
I mean I mean you're right up north
you're not eating anything you're
trekking across landscapes and running
from things all the time you should be
losing weight I mean you should be okay
look this is a fantasy show we've got
fire-breathing giant dragons we've got
ice on bees we've got a woman giving
birth to a cloud why is it me still
being fat but you just don't buy yeah
if that spotless Ron left what is your
strangest confrontation you've had with
the fan well I told it earlier today I
was standing having a drink and this
woman ran towards me with her hand like
that for my crotch a woman a woman tried
to grab your crotch yeah just - and I
said what are you doing mom he's here
yes and so did she explain it well what
are you doing [ __ ] I just wanted to
check there was something there so two
hours later
[Applause]
yeah how's this for ya
Hanna you've had some trouble with loose
lips is that true
maybe letting some things slip about
what's gonna be happening in a show and
that's gotten you in a little bit
trouble I should not be trusted with any
knowledge and no I went through I think
I just finished filming season 5 and I
went straight to a friend's birthday
party and and I told him that Jon Snow
was gonna die
what well let's set this up the door
opens I'm glad you made it John still
gonna die and he just said cuz he loves
the show and he was like it's my
birthday I mean you didn't tell me as
ever but why are you telling me on my
birthday at my birthday party it was
yeah that's awful
is here Sophie you've been on the show
since you were what 14 13 13
you've that's growing up fast I would
think to be on that set with everything
it's happening was that difficult to
grow up that quickly well yeah and also
I mean that my parents sat me down when
I was like 15 and they're like I think
it's time to talk about the birds and
the bees and I was like a monkey I don't
think I need any education I got it all
sussed out in the first episode I mean
Tyrion and Ron's they're just going at
it
remember that pop yes yes we remember
that yes he remember it it's good when
you rewind it to Maisie
maybe you almost missed out on your
audition for gaming
[Laughter]
I nearly missed out on my first game of
Thrones audition because I wanted to go
on a school trip to a pig farm because I
was really down for that
I have no idea I was thinking I was like
oh I'm gonna miss a school trip and like
it's where my own clothes don't have to
wear school uniform oh I did schoolgirl
everyone else nettly comic-con famous
for you know sort of fans geeks nerds
whatever they want to call themselves
you are a self-proclaimed nerd is that
right yeah
what you've taken it you have actual
proof that you are yeah take this stuff
pretty seriously science fiction yeah I
mean I have I have an original I have an
original Blade Runner poster at home I
was lucky enough to get Ridley Scott to
sign when I work with him and I also
have a tattoo which some of you might
know this little novel sci-fi novel want
to be original from which all the shows
we love probably spurned from is do we
I'm being told we are completely out of
time
I'm sorry I'm sorry we are what's that
no they only really give us an hour and
if we go longer than that it just
smashes into something else on this
network I don't remember what yeah
please don't yell out the answer I want
to thank everyone from Game of Thrones
I'm so sorry that we just couldn't keep
talking because I think we could do this
for hours
[Applause]
[Music]